pictures and headlines from the war in
ukraine are flooding social media and
news outlets and many parents are
concerned about how their children are
processing everything we spoke with four
parents whose children rage in age for
age from five to twenty years old they
told us about the conversations they've
had with their kids and what worries
them the most
as a former social studies teacher i
want my girls to know what's going on in
the world i want them to pay attention
and i want them to care but certainly
not at the risk of their mental health
you want to make sure that
even the stress that you have as a
parent um doesn't necessarily
get related to your children when they
do not ask
that's when you start to wonder what do
you know what do you not know what
questions you have what are you worried
about what are you thinking to get a lot
of information from you know having
conversations with their peers and what
their peers related information from
what they see on social media so for me
my 12 year old one of the first things
he asked me was if this was going to
turn into world war iii and i don't i
don't know what do i say i'm worried too
how do we
make them feel safe while also
validating that there's something really
awful happening in the world and there's
a lot of kids and families who are
struggling
clinical psychologist cynthia martin of
the child mind institute joins us now to
share her advice on how to navigate
these tough conversations good morning
and let's start right there how do you
have this conversation while
still making children feel safe right
now absolutely it's an important
question and one of the pieces to first
recognize is that this is a big topic
and these are hard conversations for
parents to navigate with their children
and so first and foremost we want to
think about putting parents in the
driver's seat so parents are the ones
who are going to have the best control
over the information and be able to talk
to their children about it in a way that
conveys facts and it is developmentally
appropriate so we do want to try to get
to kids before they've heard about
things through school through social
media uh and these kids have been done
absolutely absolutely and kids are going
to hear things through social media and
at school and so as parents we want to
be opening up the conversation with them
and bringing up the topic so that they
know that there is a place to talk about
it and they know that their parents are
available to listen to what their fears
and concerns are as a young parent i
used to think that ignorance is bliss
because there's certain things that i
don't know about so i didn't feel bad
about sharing details with my kids about
what's going on outside the home but as
i got older i realized that ignorance is
causing hesitation in the home when my
kids have real questions so
is it okay to just say i don't know to
your kids
absolutely and you should say i don't
know when you don't know what you can do
as a parent is you can tell your child
that's a really good question make sure
that you validate the emotion that's
coming behind the question and then ask
turn it and ask your child more
questions because sometimes the question
that a child is asking and how we think
what we think they might be asking and
what they're really asking are two
different things
so by asking them more questions about
just something open-ended tell me some
more about that where'd that question
come from
that
exactly that opens up the floor for more
conversation more questions and then if
there are some questions that are
important for you to answer for your
child let them know that's a really good
question and i don't know the answer to
that so let me look you asked where that
question comes from is it important to
find out the source of where this
curiosity derives from it can be and
it's going to vary a lot based on the
child's age so teens especially they
they're not getting most of their the
information from their parents they're
getting information exactly exactly
exactly and most parents aren't as into
it as their kids are or even if you
think you're into it you're probably not
included in the same way your children
are right so you want to make sure that
you're having that you have some
oversight and some control over your
child's social media use as well as
really opening up the
stage for those conversations so that
your child knows if they heard something
or saw something on social media maybe
even when they weren't supposed to be on
it
they can come to their parent and talk
about that so dr martin i thought this
was a really interesting question we got
from one mom her name is theodora lau
she wanted to know is too much
information a bad thing is it okay to
hold back certain details especially
when you see some of the horrific images
that are coming out even the front page
of the new york times a couple of days
ago had that stark photo uh taken by
lindsay dario that showed
what's happening in ukraine is that too
much for kids yeah absolutely we do want
to limit
limit and control what a child is
exposed to and we want to do that based
on the child's age it needs to be
developmentally appropriate so there are
a lot of news outlets that are
appropriate for children and
present things in a factual but more
developmentally appropriate way and
leave out some of the details that are
going to be too upsetting for a child to
be able to process because we have to
keep in mind that our kids even though
some kids come across as very mature and
very eloquent in the way they speak and
logically they're saying a lot of things
that make sense just where they are in
terms of their development and their
brain development there's going to be a
discrepancy between what they can ask
and logically try to explain and where
their emotional reasoning should you
should one of the things my parents used
to do with me is give me the newspaper
or take me to the library if i wanted to
understand the historical context of
what was happening in the world around
me what do you think about that i think
that's a good idea and i think that that
worked at that that time
what are you trying to say doctor
it's a different world now vlad
the world before the internet yeah i
think when you were going to the library
things were working
called library yes you said that so
diplomatically to black
send this message by pidgin
not that old cynthia thank you so much
this is valuable information we
appreciate hope to see you soon